schön dass sie dabei sind an diesem darf
man sagen historischen freitag kurz vor
dem zweiten advent meine damen und
herren werden wir alle reich beschenkt
mit einer neuen cdu-vorsitzenden
annegret kramp-karrenbauer der legendäre
zungenbrecher aus dem saarland hat es
endlich nach ganz oben geschafft hoch
spannender tag in hamburg wissen sie
aber am ende war es dann doch genau das
duell das alle erwartet hatten ak gegen
märz sparen sparen ja was sagt man da
achtungserfolg sagt man dazu glaube ich
51,7 prozent ganz knapper vorsprung
führt annegret jede menge versöhnliche
töne fairer verlierer und schiefer
vergleichen
dies gilt natürlich für uns drei für
eine gerät friedrich und für mich wir
sind ja so ein bisschen wie eine
rockband wir waren in den letzten wochen
wie so eine art rock band
bei allem respekt aber ihr seid wirklich
das exakte gegenteil von einer rockband
wenn überhaupt dann black rock band
die müden carlo gestartet aber die
entscheidende frage lautet natürlich
meine das jetzt ernst dieses ganze
harmonische gesetze oder gibt es jetzt
doch katerstimmung im märz lager droht
irgendeiner art spaltung ich glaube
jedenfalls die kanzlerin hatte heute
echt die hosen gestrichen voll
dass ihr alter erzfeind märz gewinnen
könnte hier bei der stichwahl
während die anderen fröhlich ihre blöden
wahl kartons aufbauen hatte ich das
gefühl so richtig bock hat die merkel
nicht aber ich meine klar muss man auch
verstehen für die frau beginnt heute
eine art abschied auf raten meine damen
und herren
ja ist ja so wie lange wird das noch gut
gehen mit der kanzlerschaft und das war
schon auffällig wie sie nach ihrer rede
von der ganzen cdu aber noch mal so
richtig gefeiert wurde in hamburg
die erleichterung im saal war mit händen
zu greifen über zehn minuten applaus ja
jetzt wo du aufhörst lieben würde ich
total ja immer das war ekstase pur und
sie hören es kommt doch schon zu
ansatzweise zumal die situation im
positiven sinne
tumult after situation ja einige
delegierte sollen sich sogar spontan die
krawatten gelockert haben meine damen
und herren
deshalb bin ich damals nämlich cdu
eingetreten die sind mir einfach zu
crazy merkels lieblings thronfolgerin
übernimmt also den parteivorsitz und man
kann es ja auch so sehen
auf eine art hat der märz heute
vielleicht tierisch glück gehabt ja er
kann jetzt in all den aufsichtsräten
bleiben ja doch auch schön oder cdu
fordert ist ein ehrenamt klassischer
looser jobs könne geredet jetzt machen
als neue chefin ist egal
und sind wir mal ehrlich hkk sieg war
jetzt keine überraschung in dem sinne
sie war schließlich merkels
ausdrückliche wunsch kandidaten hat man
schon an ihrem blick gesehen
sie erinnern sich als sie die andere
gerät im frühjahr als neue
generalsekretärin vorgestellt hat hier
stehen die beide und merkel denkt ja
heute passt kein blatt mehr zwischen die
beiden ja da ist heute echt was passiert
ja frau k k cups geschafft dabei waren
die märz fans sich ihrer sache so sicher
die waren sich so sicher dass fritze
gewinnt schäubles wunschkandidat der
liebling der kompletten deutschen
wirtschaft ja die hatten ja schon an der
cdu zentrale
die buchstaben ausgewechselt ja so
sicher waren die sich woran hat es also
gelegen da gibt es verschiedene theorien
eine lautet nur neun prozent der
deutschen finden wir hat sympathisch
werden nicht viel
außerdem hat er offensichtlich ein
problem bei frauen was er aber partout
nicht einsehen will
26 prozent der wählerinnen wollen sie
nur als parteichef haben sie ein
frauenproblem ich habe auch sehr viele
unterstützung gerade bei den frauen
bekommen wenn ich meine post richtig
lese dann sind das zur hälfte mindestens
zur hälfte frauen die mir schreiben auch
ganz junge frauen ich ein frauenproblem
mein briefkasten quillt morgens über vor
schlimmeren trauerte es war eine ganz
andere theorie es war doch nicht so eine
tolle idee von ihm kurz vor der wahl
noch mal für altersvorsorge durch aktien
zu trommeln und das als aufsichtsrat von
blackrock hat der bodenständige
multimillionär aus dem sauerland wird
das gefühl für den kleinen mann verloren
es kommt darauf an dass man in jungen
jahren anfängt mit kleinen beiträgen und
das können schon vier oder fünf euro am
tag seien ja was du in 5 euro ist das
problem
wie lange muss friedrich merz für fünf
euro arbeiten
10 11 sekunden
kleiner haken über die hälfte der
deutschen kann sich auch fünf am tag
nicht leisten aber danke für den
anlagetipps so was passiert heute abend
noch es wird gefeiert natürlich in
hamburg von einigen und die kanzlerin
über gibt wohl annegret kramp
karrenbauer in den nächsten stunden
ihren geheimen survival koffer und da
ist wirklich alles drin was du für einen
erfolgreichen cdu fordert braucht
erstmal die liste mit allen
cdu-mitgliedern denen man auf keinen
fall trauen darf dann natürlich ihren
bestseller meine 1000 leckersten
kartoffel suchen rezepte und das aller
aller wichtigste die tagesdosis
beruhigungsspritzen für horst seehofer
ganz wichtig heute beginnt also eine
neue ära in der geschichte der letzten
deutschen volkspartei bescheid mal live
in die hamburger messe halle zu albrecht
humboldt seit frühster jugend
cdu-mitglied albrecht der parteitag geht
ja morgen weiter wie ist denn jetzt die
stimmung
na das ist ja mal ne echt intelligente
frage wie ist denn die stimmung nachdem
die grösste kanzlerin die je gelebt hat
vom hof gejagt wurde wie ein räudiger
köter von ihrer eigenen scheiß partei
hier guck mal die die feinen delegierten
trinken nicht mehr richtig aus die
arschlöcher
wir haben es ja ja ja entschuldigung
frau merkel hat das doch selber so
entschieden albrecht und sie geht nach
18 jahren parteivorsitz und klar die ist
seit 18 jahren im amt aber der das lahme
internet offen land hat der hat das doch
jetzt erst erfahren
sie waren doch noch gar nicht fertig mit
ihrer politik gibt noch so viele themen
die sie noch nicht ausgesessen hat und
wie gern hätte ich noch miterlebt wie
sie dass diese probleme nicht löst sie
hat doch noch so viel nicht vor
ich glaube dass ist noch ihr lippenstift
ein glas wirklich alberich man scheint
sich ja geklappt sehen sie es doch mal
so ein wechsel ist doch eine chance für
das land ich meine endlich bewegt sich
mal was bewegen keiner hat sich so
bewegt wie die kanzlerin
niemand hat diese natürliche und
gazellen hafte eleganz hier wer soll
denn diese frau ersetzen auch als
athletin und es hätte auch noch so viele
farben für hosenanzüge gegeben
mit einem hauch von mint sind mit einem
hauch von bsb schmidt bis die fanta4
hatten völlig recht jetzt ist sie weg
und ich bin wieder allein aber kaka märz
dieser sauerland catweazle tyler hat ihr
format und ihre bescheidenheit wenn ich
ein tier sein müsste dann wäre ich gerne
nadler was werden sie denn gern vereins
habe ich mir auch noch keine gedanken
hatte ich habe immer als lieblingstier
manchmal die kröte genannt
sie könnte jedes tier sein und nimmt die
kröte
und jetzt ist meine kleine kröte welt
auf die krötenwanderung da drüben sollte
der scheibe der verräter ja du bist
schuld wohl ich hasse dich ja ja doch
nicht so blöd kann über werde was welt
sah ich habe mir von niemandem etwas
sagen wenn ihr meine angela merkel kann
dann mache ich jetzt auch was ich will
so black mich die sucht nach
ausgerutscht ich das sofort auf ich ja
wir haben nicht wie immer albrecht und
meine damen und herren vielen dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]